drew says uh in atlanta hi drew
welcome to the ramsay show hey dave
how's it going
better than i deserve how can we help
so basically i was just wondering what
the best way
to allocate my current income is in
terms of
investing you know i'm investing in a
401k
building up my checking account amount
but i also have 550
000 in a brokerage account as a result
of
some good investing from an inheritance
over the last
about 14 years so i just want to know
i'm doing the right things um
putting my money towards the best um
investment possibilities right now
okay so you inherited 550 000.
i inherited about 280 um
back in 2007. so okay it's just built up
and you've had it invested in what
mutual funds and stocks about 75
mutual funds and or 75 and then
to rest in stocks okay and how old are
you
24. okay good um
well i don't play single stocks there's
too much risk for me uh
and i buy two things for investing
um and i don't i don't recommend people
do things that i don't do
that would be hypocritical and so i buy
real estate that i pay cash for
as an as an investment in other words of
income producing real estate
and i buy mutual funds uh single stocks
more than 10 percent of your portfolio
in single stocks is too much risk for me
because i don't like losing money and
the numbers on singles playing single
stocks are not that good
but for the individual so um if i woke
up in your shoes
i would move that money into good mutual
funds with a good smart vester pro
and i wouldn't use a brokerage account
uh and
uh i think you'll end up doing better in
the long haul it'll be a lot more boring
uh but boring is good as far as i'm
concerned
exciting means there's a chance i'm
about to lose some money and i don't
like exciting
so so um
you know that's what i would do with
that money and then
uh you know what do you make a year 60
000
okay and what i would do is just go
about living my life as if that money
isn't there and it sounds like
that's what you've done so far
absolutely yes
yeah and um uh are you married do you
own a home or anything like that
no none of that okay well i would make
sure you had no debt and that you're
putting 15
of your income away for retirement and
that you're growing your career and that
you're living intentionally on a budget
uh now i would use some of that 550 out
of those mutual funds to pay cash for my
first house when you're married and get
ready to do that or when you just decide
you're going to buy a house and there's
no rush in that you're 24 if you didn't
buy a house for two or three more years
it wouldn't be that big a deal yeah
and so you know let that money grow and
sit there
and you're paying cash for everything if
you can learn to live as if that money's
not
there except for the fact you pay cash
for a house later
um that's going to cause you that that's
going to
take this pile of money and make it tens
of millions
yeah because you got 40 plus years for
this money to parlay
and um if you're invested in good mutual
funds and making
uh you know 10 or so that money's gonna
double about every seven years
yeah and so seven years from today when
you are uh
31 years old you'd have a million one
seven years later when you're 38
you would have two million two
seven years later when you're 45 you'd
have 4 million
for good crisis and that's if you don't
mess with this and it just sits there in
decent mutual funds and grows at a
decent rate
um and so again you pull some of that
out you buy a house with it then you
take what
was going to be a house payment and
invest that you'll end up in exactly the
same place
you just you just used your own money
and now you're putting your money back
in the form of a payment uh and so and
as your career goes on
so this money literally you should be
worth
over 10 million dollars when you hit
retirement as a result of this
so very very nice gift as an inheritance
and you will be one of those
millionaires that
are a millionaire because of an
inheritance which by the way is a very
unusual thing statistically
and a wonderful gift from uh
whoever did a great job with money in
the last generation that left it to you
uh pretty cool situation man i i'm
sitting here just going over
the numbers in in my head dave like drew
if he does the right
thing today the caliber of his future is
so
bright if he just sits there at like the
money is not there and he's continuing
to put money into it
he's just adding fuel to a positive fire
for his future and guess what there's a
high probability he's going to do that
yeah and there's two indicators of that
one is he was probably raised or
influenced by whoever did this the first
time and left him the money yep
and two we know that because he's had
this money yeah
for a while and has doubled it already
and three
he called in and asked us and asked us
yeah he was the right way he didn't go
buy a lamborghini yup
yup and which i'm i got to say i'm
surprised you know for 20 something
sitting on
almost i'm not surprised because he was
raised by the people that did that
and so uh you know so the rule is for
your parents then
uh your grandparents then and i'm
talking to myself as well legacy journey
book
is more caught than taught your main
inheritance is knowledge and character
and if you leave them money without
knowledge and or character
you will raise a kid in a reality show
but if you leave them uh character and
knowledge
uh without money they will get money yup
but if you leave them character
knowledge and money
now you've changed your family tree yes
sir and that's what's happened with drew
don't you just sense he's mature beyond
his years absolutely that's what i'm
like man if
i'm just excited for his future yeah